en física hay una ley que ha superado la
prueba del tiempo algunas cosas vienen y
van hay nuevos descubrimientos que se
descartan modifican y ajustan sin
embargo esta ley jamás ha sido ni será
modificada ni se ha realizado
experimento que la haya contradicho esta
es la ley de la conservación de la carga
y nos referimos a la carga eléctrica que
es de lo que hablaremos en este ejemplo
imaginen que tenemos una caja
y adentro vamos a poner algunas cargas
por ejemplo aquí tenemos una partícula
de más dos kilos y por acá tenemos otra
partícula volando de menos tres kilos
y de este otro lado tenemos otra carga
de 5 kilos
éstas se encuentran flotando en la caja
y la ley de la conservación de la carga
nos dice que si está cerrada en el
sentido de que ninguna carga puede
entrar o salir
si ese es el caso la carga total dentro
de esta región del espacio tiene que ser
constante cuando la sumamos todas si
pusiéramos esto como un enunciado
matemático y a mí me gustan las
matemáticas
el enunciado matemático es la suma
usamos sigma como una forma elegante de
denotar la suma la suma de todas las
cargas en una región en específico
siempre y cuando aquí está el asterisco
no hayan cargas que entren o salgan de
esta región si esto se cumple entonces
la suma de todas las cargas será
constante aunque esto nos parezca
complicado en realidad es bastante
sencillo quiere decir que sumemos todas
las cargas más 2 collins más 5 kilos
menos 3 kilos nos va a dar un número que
va a representar la carga total en esta
región y que es 2 + 5 -siete menos 3 6-4
otros positivos y cada que abramos esta
caja nos encontraremos cuatro colores
positivos lo cual les puede parecer
demasiado obvio pues si no entran ni
salen cargas pues claro que esto va a
permanecer constante porque tenemos
solamente tres cargas pero esto no
siempre se cumple ya que dos partículas
podrían colisionar estas partículas no
tienen porqué mantener sus identidades
quizás podría terminar con ocho
partículas aquí en algún momento del
tiempo pero si sumo todas las cargas
seguiré teniendo cuatro columnas y esto
hace que esta ley no sea obvia o frívola
esto es algo útil porque si imaginamos
que estas partículas fueran protones que
no lo son porque los protones tienen una
carga diferente a la de dos culos pero
para este ejemplo digamos que es un
protón
esta es otra partícula quizá un electrón
colisione con el protón a gran velocidad
y si tienen suficiente energía puede que
no terminemos con un protón y un
electrón quizá terminemos con gluones o
quarks y con este protón podríamos
terminar con partículas de hicks o lo
que sea por lo que más adelante en el
tiempo y aquí veremos por qué es
importante esta ley y no es trivial si
esto está completamente cerrado y lo
único que ocurre adentro se debe a las
partículas que ya están ahí cualquier
partícula o partículas descendientes
creadas por éstas
por ejemplo más adelante en el tiempo
puedo encontrarme con otra partícula que
quizá no tenga la misma carga a lo mejor
tiene un culo positivo y quizá por acá
tengo una carga de menos 7 culos si esas
fueran partículas elementales tendrían
cargas mucho más pequeñas
para comprender mejor esta idea nos
conviene usar números grandes así que
digamos que aquí hay otra partícula de
cuatro colores y también tenemos otra
partícula más ninguna de esas partículas
las teníamos anteriormente esta
partícula tiene una carga que de alguna
manera terminamos con estas cuatro
partículas quién sabe cómo se combinaron
y reaccionaron las partículas originales
cuál será la carga q de esta partícula
podemos responder a esta pregunta sin
problemas conocemos la carga de las
otras partículas y sabemos que si
sumamos todas las cargas tendremos como
resultado la misma cantidad que tuvimos
con anterioridad tendremos como
con anterioridad pues la ley de la
conservación de la carga nos dice que si
no dejamos entrar y salir ninguna carga
entonces la suma de las cargas debe
mantenerse constante
vamos a hacerlo vamos a sumar todas las
cargas 1 positivo más 7 negativo
más menos 4
más cuál sea la carga q que tenemos aquí
de nuestra partícula misteriosa y todo
está en q los sabemos que la suma de
todo esto debe ser igual a la carga
total que encontramos con anterioridad
de más 4 kilos pues este número no
cambia si antes teníamos una carga total
de 4 colom es positivo entonces ahora
debemos tener también cuatro colores
positivo como carga total porque esto es
lo que nos dice la ley de la
conservación de la carga todo esto debe
ser igual a más cuatro colores menos 7
menos 4 nos da menos 11 más 1 nos da
menos 10 colores más la q nos da igual a
4 colores
por lo que nuestra partícula misteriosa
tiene una carga de 14 kilos para poder
satisfacer esta ecuación
pero en realidad no necesitamos una caja
es decir en física no hacemos
experimentos en cajas de cartón digamos
que vamos a hacer un experimento y
tenemos una partícula x que tiene cierta
cantidad de carga que es de tres colores
lo cual es una carga enorme para una
partícula pero digamos que esta es la
carga que tiene esta partícula va a
decaer a veces las partículas se
descomponen desaparecen convirtiéndose
en otras partículas en este caso digamos
que se descompone en la partícula
y en la partícula zeta les damos nombres
aleatorios y descubrimos que la
partícula james tiene una carga de dos
culos positivo y la partícula zeta tiene
una carga de un color negativo es
posible que esto ocurra pues no esto no
es posible si ustedes se encuentran algo
así entonces algo no está bien porque de
este lado comenzamos con tres culpamos
positivo y de acuerdo con la ley de la
conservación de la carga
debemos terminar de este lado con una
carga de 3
es positivo pero dos culos positivos
menos un culo nos da un culo en positivo
por lo que se nos han perdido dos culos
a donde se fueron pues tiene que haber
una partícula misteriosa que no vimos ya
sea porque funciona mal el detector y
simplemente no detectó esta partícula
que tiene otra cantidad de carga cuánta
carga debería tener sabemos que la suma
total nos debe dar 3 ya que esta fue la
cantidad inicial y como la suma de estos
dos nos da un color entonces los dos
colores que nos faltan están aquí
debemos tener una partícula perdida con
una carga de 2 q lo más positivo
quizá fue otra partícula y puede que sí
y es por eso que la física es divertida
ahora déjenme preguntarles esto vamos a
quitar todas estas cargas y esto es algo
que asusta a varias personas tenemos
esto y digamos que no tenemos carga es
una partícula no cargada con cero
colores es posible terminar con
partículas que tengan carga claro que es
posible de hecho si tenemos un fotón
este no tiene carga y es posible que
este fotón se transforme en partículas
cargadas como es posible esto no va en
contra de la ley de la conservación de
la carga pero debemos asegurarnos de que
al sumar todas las cargas por ejemplo
este tiene tres colones positivos y esta
otra tiene tres q lo más negativos
debemos asegurarnos que la suma de todas
las cargas sea de 0 colom es igual que
lo que tuvimos al inicio
esto es extraño un fotón o un rayo de
luz puede descomponerse en un electrón
pero también tiene que descomponerse en
un anti electrón ya que la suma de todas
las cargas debe ser igual a cero y un
anti electrón tiene la misma carga que
un electrón pero con signo positivo en
lugar de negativo es por eso que se le
llama positrón al anti electrón tiene la
misma carga pero positiva ustedes no
necesitan conocer esto ni necesitan
conocer mucho sobre la física de
partículas ese es el punto aquí solo con
conocer la conservación de la carga
podemos hacer enunciados sobre la física
de las partículas porque sabemos que la
carga debe conservarse lo que es una
herramienta poderosa para el análisis de
estas reacciones en términos de lo que
es posible y lo que no es posible